what's up everyone I'm Alex new house
here at e3 2016 I'm here with Mike
McCarty who just played halo wars 2 yeah
how was it Mike it's it's kind of
different from a la Wars one but it's
also kind of very similar you know like
Halo Wars one was more of an RTS game
made for Halo fans it's not really the
deepest RTS game but in doing so you
know ensemble Studios who made Halo Wars
you know they succeeded right they made
this game that Halo fans could really
sink into and kind of you know like it
was very accessible for console controls
in the controller with Halo Wars to its
creative assembly no one probably for
their work on you know like the Total
War series so they're very experienced
the RTS developer now they're kind of
you know taking the reins of a halo wars
franchise and it kind of shows right
that experience because you have more
units that are kind of diverse in how
you actually position them how you can
kind of flank how these units kind of
play between each other it was it's not
the same basic rock paper scissor
framework of the first game I that's
there but it's also much deeper this
time around and one of the big draws of
Halo Wars the original one was that it
was an RTS on a console and for that it
played pretty well how does this one
feel on the Xbox it still feels pretty
good on xbox one the chief thing being
that this is also on pc now right there
pushing Windows 10 and then after the
microsoft press conference anything you
get on one will also be available the
other so that's huge because you know
you have control groups right when
you're playing on PC you have the mouse
moving around the screen it's much more
intuitive and flow is much better now
that I have the pc can to compare to the
Xbox one I don't see myself playing on
xbox one but xbox one players will be
set it still feels great you know you
hold our be to select all your units you
like DoubleTap it to select a unit of
that type on the screen you know you're
still pretty basic you're just moving
the analog stick to pressing X to move
to execute a command holding L trigger
to pull up the command options like the
Mac blast or the Lotus mines you could
drop or the ODST which is my favorite
just drop the hell jumpers in it feels
great on both i prefer the pc there are
some little tweaks that i notice that
they don't have yet like i couldn't just
hover over the mini map and tell me
units where to go on that i had to
actually go to where I want them to go
and then click it which is kind of again
like that's just the RTS phantom ii
speaking there's some minor things I'd
like to see but oh we're all is a pretty
positive experience i played strongholds
or kind of comparing it to like the
domination mode a shooter right it's
there's these seven outposts in between
all your bases and it pretty much forces
to be pretty aggressive and I'm
traditionally a turtle player so I kind
of got out of my comfort zone which I
like you take these outposts if you can
get seven and hold it for a minute you
win or when timer runs out the more
outputs you have you win so that was
just the one game mode they had
available for us yeah and I'm a huge
halo nerd so I'm super interested in
this story when does halo wars 2 story
take place you take place right after
Hitler wars won so yeah they're calling
a direct sequel it's 28 years after so I
sensibly that be before reach falls
right no the other new fact is the
banished uh I don't know too much the
leader is it so they're a brute faction
leader is a tree ox and he uses covenant
weaponry although their name implies
they're not associated with the Covenant
and then you have you know the UNSC and
kind of the interplay between them I'm
really curious as to what the actual
story will cover right because this is
kind of that gap between halo wars which
is the earliest in the chronologically
in the games and then you have you know
hey lafave reach our halo sorry reaches
the next one so interesting to see how
the bridge that gap but right now we
don't know a ton so I'm kind of looking
forward to finding out more well I'm
sure we'll find out more about the story
in the coming months when does it come
out again febuary of next year cool but
in the meantime you can keep an eye on
gamespot for more news about all games
coming out of III 2016
you